creció en una familia en donde hablar
del dinero era un tema tabú y lleno de
cargas emocionales yo sabía que había
dinero en mi casa cuando todo el mundo
estaba relajado y contento me compraban
el nintendo y estábamos viendo a ver que
estábamos planeando pero sabía cuando no
había dinero porque era como si la
molestia y la preocupación se apoderaron
de mi familia desde entonces supe que
era un tema súper difícil de tratar por
lo menos en mi casa porque se veía como
superficial o materialista o hasta poco
espiritual y sé que muchas personas
pueden pensar que no les interesa el
tema del dinero pero el hecho de que tú
estés viendo esta plática desde tu
celular o desde una computadora quiere
decir que tú o alguien más lo utilizo
como medio de intercambio y hoy te
quiero hablar de él como lo que es como
un medio de intercambio me importa qué
tipo de día quieras llevar ya sea que
quieras llevar una vida minimalista o
quieras dejar por el mundo o quieras
construir escuelas esta es la mejor
herramienta que hoy tenemos y así empezó
mi búsqueda quería entender cómo era que
funcionaba el dinero y creo que
inconscientemente por eso
a trabajar en bancos y en casas de bolsa
primero aquí en méxico y después en eeuu
y me acuerdo que los primeros días que
llegué a la casa de bolsa empecé a
escuchar palabras que en mi vida había
escuchado escucha a palabras como plane
vanilla forward cup de taza y en ese
momento pensé como me voy a poder
entender con el tema del dinero sin ni
siquiera sé su lenguaje y a eso me
dediqué compré todos los diccionarios
financieros y todos los diccionarios
bancarios y leía todos los libros de
inversiones y después de un tiempo me
convertí en la experta en tema de
coberturas cambiarios a tal grado que
hice un fondo que genera el mayor
rendimiento dentro de la institución en
el menor tiempo
y efectivamente mi relación con el
dinero mejoro sólo que era de la puerta
de mi casa hacia afuera porque la puerta
en mi casa hacia adentro estaba peor que
nunca
claro que ganábamos dinero pero gastaba
mucho más estaba mucho más endeudada no
tenía un peso ahorrado y en la única
bolsa que invertía menos la que traía
colgada con cero pesos adentro
después de esto me sentí como una
farsante porque sabía que había personas
que me hablaban para consultarme qué
iban a hacer con su dinero cuando yo no
tenía ni idea de qué hacer con el mío y
trabajar en este tipo de instituciones
te permite ver muchas historias de cerca
a mí me tocó ver personas llorar porque
van a perder su casa porque tenían un
crédito hipotecario y no tenían dinero
para pagar ese crédito pero también me
otras historias en donde las personas
eran como responsables de su vida y van
construyendo exactamente lo que querían
si querían mandar a sus hijos de
estudiar al extranjero lo podían hacer
sin ninguna angustia y me empecé a
enfocar en esas historias porque sabían
que tenía como común denominador
y eso es lo que hoy te vengo a contar su
secreto así tal cual
ws y h y la primera ese es de saber la
segunda de sentir y la tercera letra la
h
es de hacer
porque estas personas saben cinco
conceptos que hoy te voy a decir la
segunda s de sentir es que sienten igual
que tú y que yo y que todo el mundo
pero la diferencia es que ellos saben
gestionar sus emociones y por último la
h de hacer es que ellos toman este
conocimiento gestionan estas emociones y
actúan de manera de que les empieza a
generar los resultados que quieren en su
vida entonces nos vamos a ir por partes
primero les voy a practicar la s de
saber y si no tienen con que anotar
vayan por una pluma y anoten porque esto
es la receta y la primera es que siempre
ahorran antes de gastar para mí era casi
imposible yo siempre pensaba que iba a
ahorrar lo que me quedara después de
gastar el tema era que nunca me quedaba
nada ni siquiera cuando empecé a ganar
más dinero la segunda es que tienen
presupuestos ellos saben perfectamente a
dónde se va su dinero y ahora que me
dedico a dar talleres de finanzas
personales hay muchas personas que me
dicen yo no pasar un presupuesto porque
no tengo ingresos fijos pues no pero
probablemente tienes gastos fijos y
desde ahí podemos comenzar la tercera es
que siempre protegen su patrimonio tiene
seguro de carro tienen seguro de casa
tiene seguro de gastos médicos mayores
y claro que tienen de repente tienen
accidentes pero la ventaja es que se va
a levantar bien rápido la tercera es que
siempre invierte y no siempre ganan
dinero cuando pierde lo toman como un
aprendizaje y lo integran para tomar
mejores decisiones la próxima vez y por
último las deudas claro que se endeudan
pero a diferencia de las deudas que yo
tenía que era con la tienda
departamental para comprarme la bolsa o
los zapatos ellos se endeudan solamente
para generar más activos y así fue como
supe que había perdido muchísimo tiempo
aprendiendo me tantos conceptos tan
complejos cuando la respuesta está ahí
en cinco pasos super simples y super
fáciles de entender pero sabía que
faltaban piezas dentro de la ecuación y
ahí fue cuando se me apareció la segunda
es la que les dije de sentir
y se me apareció sin siquiera buscarlo
fue un día que amanecí con parálisis
facial y a quien no le ha tocado ver qué
es lo que pasa cuando te ha parálisis
facial a mí se me hizo el ojo así no lo
podía cerrar la boca se me caía y cuando
tomaba agua se me caía todo el agua y me
colgaron el teléfono muchas veces porque
cuando hablaba parecía que estaba ebria
y me acuerdo que fui con el neurólogo y
me dijo natalia no te preocupes a ti se
te agitar en un mes nada más tienes que
hacer todo lo que yo te diga y empiezo a
hacer todo lo que me dijo mi hijo toma
vitamina b12 ve con la acupuntura haz
los masajes todo hice pero ese mes se
convirtió en dos años y yo no recuperaba
mi movilidad
y ahí estaba la segunda es esperando que
la reconociera y supe que estas personas
tienen una gestión emocional diferente a
la que yo tenía y quiero empezar a
platicarles de la primera de la alegría
porque es la que mejor reputación tiene
y esta alegría es la que te empuja a que
empieces a hacer todo para que empieces
ese emprendimiento oa que inviertas
porque te asocias con el primo y
empiezan a ser restaurante con el que
siempre han soñado pero también es la
responsable y la que te aconseja que
apenas te dan un aumento te vayas a
comprar una casa más grande o que te dan
el bono y que te lo vayas a gastar o que
te vayas de viaje porque claro que te lo
mereces el tema es que no le puedes dar
el control de tu vida la alegría te
puede tapar los ojos y no ver los
riesgos a los que te puedes enfrentar
cada vez que vas a hacer una inversión
la segunda emoción es la tristeza esa
que te va a estar esperando ahí para que
yo eres con ella cada vez que tengas una
perdida cada vez que pierda su trabajo
cada vez que llegue tu socio y te digo
que ya no quieres seguir contigo ella es
la que va a estar ahí
y por algún momento en mi vida yo le
permití que tomar el control y me
aconsejó que dejara mi emprendimiento de
lado que mejor medicar algo más seguro y
que me regresar a trabajar en una
empresa y le hice caso pero un día me
llena de valentía y trate de controlarla
o más bien la controle y la corrida en
mi vida le dije que yo era quien tenía
el control y me la tuve que sacudir
y la tienes que correr lo más rápido que
puedas porque si llega y se instala está
ya con más letras y de repente se te
convierte en una depresión entonces en
el momento en que la sientas llora la
siente la pero corre el a lo más rápido
que puedas porque ella es la responsable
de que te quedes tirado a medio camino o
que te levantes muchísimo más fuerte y
así fue como aprendí de ella a ser más
fuerte a ser más resiliente y a seguir
adelante con más inteligencia
la tercera emoción el enojo que para mí
era como este emoción que estaba
prohibida porque realmente la veía como
la emoción que más destruía porque te
puede destruir todo desde sociedades
contratos familias todo
y aprendí a verla como algo que te puede
ayudar a reconstruir todo con mejores
bases y con mejores cimientos porque el
enojo se va a presentar en tu vida cada
vez que sientas que alguien se está
pasando en la línea cada vez que tú veas
una injusticia aído estar dándote esa
fuerza para que vuelvas a reestructurar
todo que encuentres el equilibrio y que
puedas hacer todo desde unas bases mucho
más fuertes y sólidas
y por último el miedo el miedo que
obviamente me va a acompañar el día de
hoy porque tengo pánico de estar aquí
parada pero decidí que me iba a llevar
bien con él porque este se aparece cada
vez que quieras hacer algo nuevo y a mí
me encanta hacer cosas nuevas
y supe relacionarme con él y ahora lo
veo directamente a los ojos y le
pregunto qué me quieres enseñar porque
siempre trae un mensaje a veces me dice
que me cuide que me proteja o también
que tengo que desarrollar nuevas
habilidades porque esto que se nos viene
enfrente no sabemos cómo manejar ya es
así como aprendí que nuestro miedo puede
ser nuestro gran aliado pero lo que sí
te pido es que no le des el control de
tu vida porque el miedo por protegerte
te va a paralizar y así fue como supe
que saber y sentir eran partes bien
importantes de nuestra relación con el
dinero pero me faltaba la hache de hacer
y esa ni la busqué ni me encontró es a
mi esposo me la presentó porque para él
si yo lo pudiera describir en una sola
frase él es diciendo y haciendo él es de
esas personas que puede llevar toda la
acción en el momento en que se le está
ocurriendo y yo no sabía hacerlo y me
empecé a dar cuenta que tenía cuatro
obstáculos
el primero el poquito me la pasaba
porque te anda todo era poquito lo que
puede ahorrar era un poquito lo que
puede invertir un poquito lo que iba a
ganar con la inversión era poquito
y así me paralicé muchísimo tiempo pero
hoy estamos en la mejor época en la
historia de la humanidad para empezar
mucho con poco incluso mi propio
emprendimiento empezó con una libreta y
con una pluma pero eso sí con muchas
ganas de que la gente no pasara por lo
que yo pasé para entenderle el tema del
dinero hoy puedes tener una tienda en
línea sin ni siquiera tener el
inventario y tomar las fotografías e ir
las comprando a medida que se te las van
pagando el segundo obstáculo con el que
me topé fue con el perfeccionismo que si
le soy sincera creo que es un disfraz
que utiliza el miedo para que no lo
reconozcas el perfeccionismo está que
siempre te está diciendo que te falta
algo que te faltan credenciales que tu
producto no está terminado que tu
servicio no es lo máximo pero la
realidad es que lo perfecto no existe
entendí que es como una parte del
proceso porque el día que tú llegas a lo
perfecto según tu idea puede ser que el
mercado esté pensando otra cosa o que el
día que llegaste a la perfección algo
más te aparece
y destituya totalmente tu emprendimiento
entonces adoptarlo como una parte de tu
proceso la tercera el autosabotaje esta
vocecita que te sabe tus puntos más
débiles lo que más te da pena
yo me acuerdo que cuando iba a empezar
para mí el autosabotaje me decía que yo
era disléxico que no me sabía las tablas
de multiplicar que no había terminado mi
carrera pero lo único con lo que puedes
asustar al autosabotaje es trabajando
de esta manera esa voz empezó a
desaparecer ahorita casi ni le escucho
por último el ser víctima que esta es la
que más te puede debilitar porque todo
el mundo te falló te fallo el gobierno
te falló el sistema educativo te
fallarán tus papás te falló todo el
mundo y la verdad es que ser víctima te
debilita muchísimo porque el cambio lo
tiene que hacer alguien allá afuera y no
tú y de la única manera que te puedes
deshacer de ese papel es
responsabilizando así es que si algo no
te está funcionando es momento de eso
y si es la s de saber cierra la boca
porque se aprende leyendo escuchando y
observando si es la s de sentir calla
tus emociones y toma el control de tu
vida y si es la h
de hacer no digas que vas a hacer las
cosas atlas porque haciendo las 6 en
zonas
y me quiero despedir con dos noticias
una muy mala y una muy buena
y la muy mala es que lo único que se
interpone entre tú y lo que quieres
lograr eres tú mismo pero la muy buena
es que lo único que se interpone entre
tú y lo que quieres lograr eres tú mismo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]